wow I I love this um I love this New
York apartment you moved into I know
it's nice it's fabulous great digs I
know I love it I actually love being in
this building so much we're in the same
building now we're in the same building
now see you in the elevator I love I'm
listen I've had a milkshake burst in the
elevator too you're not the I I dropped
my matcha it went everywhere and listen
we've all done a Jackson poock in the
building so know it was my first day
man it's beautiful it's art it was also
on the ceiling I think Andy he caught
it he was trying to be nice it was
everywhere I've actually never had a
drink drop like that right well did it
drop or did it rock it to the sky I
swear to God a ghost was in the ele I I
was holding it and then I wasn't right
like and I was just standing there no
one bumped me like it just was like
welcome to the building like yeah yeah
so I trash things when I enter buildings
it's fine do have you ever had any
mishaps here oh definitely one time for
a dry mishap I um uh Rachel mat almost
like I almost Rachel M was trying to
open the door for me once this glass
door and then I kind of leaned into it
too much I could have broken through the
glass and killed us both and it would
have been a a gay scandal in the
Bild specific Scandal specific
[Music]
scandal
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home